foreign
in the context of science The Observer
problem was the reason that Heisenberg
gave up the idea that science can
discover reality he gave it up he's
written a great book about you know
physics and philosophy that's what he
says and he he founded quantum mechanics
absolutely fundamental bit of Science
and he concluded that because of the
problem of the Observer
but it isn't like what the problem of
the Observer is the problem because the
word Observer is just part of one way of
dividing the world the idea that there's
a world an observer that's one one
conceptual description
um and so it's not that the problem just
comes up because of the Observer it's
that any framework you have will have
limitations and it has limitations
because closures are not the same thing
as the stuff out there I mean I think
the point is we're arguing sort of
different things
um so what science is doing as I said is
it's trying to find rules rules that
work at some level it's not saying this
is enough but but the kind of problem
that you're raising is more like you
know if I said I was going to hey on why
and I said well where exactly does it
end well you say you might say Well it
ends here it ends a little closer and
you say well therefore I can't say
anything about hey and why I mean you
know the the fact that I'm choosing to
distinguish myself as an observer from
the external reality is just a very
practical description that allows me to
formulate physical laws that work and it
also will tell me okay it's going to
break down now because at this point you
know most times we don't have to worry
about the uncertainty principle
sometimes we do and we know when that is
and at those times we will factor that
in when we're making predictions so I
think what you're pointing out which
sign a good scientist will do is to be
aware of the assumptions and
approximations that are being made but
that is what science says well it is
more a Hawking thought when he thought
that we could have found a theory of
everything yeah so there are plenty of
scientists who don't think that and I
well that's like I said
knocking on Heaven has moved towards
because I think there were too many
people who are being anti-science and
were saying how could science be right
if it's going to change why is it a
moving Target the fact is when you're
doing science you don't you know we
learn science as like these are the laws
this is the way it works but actually as
a scientist most of the time you don't
know where you're going to end up just
like with many other fields you're not
sure that doesn't mean it's not science
it means it's not definitive and the
fact that you know your scientific
theory might change when you make more
precise measurements doesn't mean your
old scientific theory was necessarily
wrong it means it was an approximation
that now you found out the limitations
no that that's not where Hawking is he
is not saying I don't care what he says
he's not he's not saying that there are
better approximations because you're
still holding on to the idea of Truth
we're getting closer and it's getting
together
they can't choose between an ultimate
sense in which we can't choose between
but don't miss understand me I am not in
any way critical of science we as
scientists we never make absolute
statements we're all at some level we're
I mean if if we're honest I mean you can
disprove things in an absolute way if
something doesn't work it's wrong but to
actually prove a theory we can never
prove a theory because you can always
say there might be some exception that
comes up and in philosophy if you're
trying to put yourself to an artificial
scientific standard you probably also
won't make progress but there might be
questions that you can say in the
majority of times this is the kind of
conclusion we would come to so I think
if you want to use the scientific method
you should understand what it is better
well I I think that the way that there
are many ways in which the way that
Lisa's describing so it's our entirely
would would go along with and we have a
similar sort of account that it's a
temporary way of holding the world
currently and we can try and improve on
it later so so we can we can agree on
that again it's not necessarily
temporary like Newton's Laws I would say
are still true even though they're not
fundamental and that's it's just a
question of how we want to phrase that
so exactly maybe there's a terminal but
I I suspect maybe there's a little bit
more than the terminology because there
are times when although I agree with you
that that notion that we we put things
forward and we we try them out and say
when we see whether it works
um which is very much the way that I
would describe how we improve our
closures
um uh uh I I think there are times when
uh at least you still are wanting to
hold on to the idea that there is a
particular thing that you might get to
while it seems to me any theory that you
have any account you have is is not
going to be the same thing as as the
universe if you like it's it's it's a
way of holding the universe and so it's
always infinitely different and so it's
it's we can try and get uh Frameworks
that work better and better for sure and
we should be trying to do that and uh so
I say I'm I'm wanting a way to be more
rigorous about how you might go about
doing that and providing a web what does
it mean to uh to to refine your your
framework to get it to work but I think
we have to be wary of the notion that we
uh are uncover uncovering the universe
we're somehow singing into the mind of
God uh and we and we've and we've
captured it once and for all I'm not
sure could I just respond since
everyone's putting words into my mouth
um I mean I think there is a description
of science where we say we want to find
the ultimate Theory of Everything people
certainly say those words to continue
watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas